if we get this right we could rewire in
our economies to actually do good things
how many people here think that our
economies are completely running amok
and like causing all sorts of damage to
the world think about the environment
think about like I think about like what
we value today think about like the
short-term returns think about NASA
being underfunded think about how much
we pay attention to things like a
doomsday index is the Forbes list
actually an accurate representation of
what humanity values absolutely
not I'm sorry but but this is because we
don't have good credit assignment at all
we all over the place there's all sorts
of leakages where we don't have good
wiring of this and we don't have a nice
back prop system set up in place and
then you have to have people at the end
people like Elon Musk who you know
manage to to understand the game well
enough to amass a whole bunch of capital
and then say hey look like I figured out
the game I succeeded at it some one
degree and now I can do something that's
really valuable let's back up humanity
but that can't be our best way of
working that can't like we have no hope
of surviving if that's the way that we
do it and so I think we really need to
step back think about these problems and
building a much better way to encode our
values into our economy and if we do
that which is totally possible because
again money is just an invention if we
do that then we will see
just very quickly new new systems
optimising for the right things and hey
guess what it's a good time to do it
because script economics allows you to
test and play with these things